obviously we are fans of this category
and having taught animation for five
years up at calarts it's especially
gratifying for me to be with you guys
today you've done great work
congratulations as a former graduate
film student myself I appreciate the
hard work it took to get here this is an
exciting time and animation with major
advancements amazing technology I can
promise you that you will never stop
learning i graduated from theatre school
but i brought with me to animation the
same love of storytelling that we all
share the Academy received over a
hundred and twenty-one entries for the
animation category and the three winning
films are higher sky by Tang Chang from
the University of Southern California
inspired by the ancient martial art of
Kung Fu a monkey and a swallow are
locked in combat in an intense rivalry
that's something we see every day and
then there is owned by daniel clark and
wesley tippets from Brigham Young
University in Utah it shows what happens
when a super ultra mega fighter turbo
video game champion meets his match and
yamashita by Haley foster from Loyola
Marymount University in California tells
the story of a young japanese american
girls struggle with her cultural
identity and the breakdown of her family
after being forced into an internment
camp during world war two